on a beaucoup parlé des écrans depuis le
début de cette émission spéciale les
phobies la réalité virtuelle dans tout
ça on va justement parler et pour ce
faire on va se rendre au centre fuit
dans le vieux mauvais comme une
constellation
[Musique]
on voit ici comment travers la réalité
augmentée l'oeuvre prend soudainement
vie
[Musique]
ici au centre fuit à montréal pôle
artistique et culturelle le grand public
est invité à vivre des expériences de
réalité augmentée et de réalité
virtuelle on voit la réalité virtuelle a
bel et bien sa place dans le monde des
arts et c'est tant mieux mais ce n'est
pas tout la réalité virtuelle a aussi sa
place dans l'univers médical mettons le
cap sur le centre suit l universitaire
sainte-justine rencontre et la
chercheuse sylvie lomé
[Musique]
même le mais l'utilisation de la réalité
virtuelle dans un contexte de soins
hospitaliers cliniques à londres
l'objectif général
à quoi ça sert en tout premier lieu nous
on s'en faire pour distraire les enfants
lors de procédure douloureuse pour dans
font dévier l'attention de l'enfant de
la procédure parce que c'est un procédé
qui était déjà utilisé pour les adultes
depuis un certain temps déjà la réalité
virtuelle existe depuis environ 25 ans
donc elle commençait à utiliser auprès
des adultes dans les contextes de grands
brûlés de stress post traumatique doigts
qui veulent être certains qu plus
exactement donc qu'ils utilisaient la
réalité virtuelle à fond dans là pour
aider sensibiliser les aider comme un
petit de thérapie vous voulez pour le
stress post traumatique qui contrôle et
vous à quel moment vous avez décidé de
vous intéresser à cet aspect là des
choses en soient pédiatrie finalement
pour les autres et moi j'étais à la
recherche d'une intervention qui serait
immersive qui permettrait vraiment
distraction de complète de la procédure
mais justement de nous des exemples
concrets des procédures pour lesquelles
la reine et virtuel peut être utile pour
permettre à la france de se dégager
d'oublier la douleur
ce que je peux vous donner comme un
exemple c'est les enfants qu'ils ont ont
des brûlures puis on à faire débrider
leur plaît à faire nettoyer leur les
enfants qui se font retirer des broches
1 3 2 qui ont été placées initialement
pour une fracture ou des enfants qui ont
à subir des procédures impliquant des
aiguilles comme des ponction veineuse ou
déposer cathéter intraveineux donc qui
sont des procédures courte mais
douloureuse puis en oxygène anxiogène ça
c'est l'autre élément que je veux vous
amener parce que pour un enfant le fait
de savoir qui va subir d
soit comme ça comme ça c'est sacré de
l'anxiété donc donc je m'agite la
réalité virtuelle
un amour sert à le calme mais aussi il
ya toujours une anticipation une
appréhension la douleur au cou densité
nyon les mesures y en recherche
on a vu que les taux de douleur et bars
étaient pris interventions sont très
élevés et pour le personnel soignant
c'est plus facile pour le personnel
soignant en général ce qu'on a observé
c'est que ça facilite beaucoup la
procédure douloureuse parce que l'enfant
dit rien n'est pas agité il pleure pas
puis la procédure se fait plus
facilement
bon mais parlons justement de cette
distraction par quoi il est distrait
l'enfant vous avez développé un univers
virtuel et l'univers virtuel qu'on a
développés s'appelle dreamland
puisqu'on vous êtes comme dans une
nacelle puis vous voyez à travers des
hits des environnements ou à ce que des
chutes ou à ce que des des animaux des à
des petites habitations et autres
puis vous avez interagir cette ville
avaient à crever des ballons avec une
balle puis ça vous donne des points donc
vous naviguez dans cet univers-là qui
permet vraiment l'immersion complète pas
vraiment le contact avec la réalité donc
g le mais est ce que vous me dites le
moi ça me donne envie d'essayer de
plonger dans cet univers virtuel est ce
que vous permettez qu'on laissait oui
bien sûr très bien dosé alors tournez
vous et moi même sens que moi très bien
puis je voulais installe janvier mais
l'une est qu'ils allaient voir comme des
bonnes âmes qui geste
oui on a deux trois jeunes éméchés wade
voulait pointé avec m
wayana qui me marque sait faire la
douleur est sûr que l'enfant peut
entièrement faire abstraction avec ce
genre de red bull mais s'était passé
pour certains enfin que d'avoir un
vraiment un contrôle vraiment totale de
la douleur je vois très clairement ce
que vous dites qu'un enfant peut être
absorbé par sa oublier la douleur
oui complètement waouh quelle aventure
qu'elles voyagent mal à me lever
merci beaucoup vu alors si je comprends
bien le but ultime de votre démarche
c'est qu'en bout de ligne ça soit
intégrée dans les soins hospitaliers
oui tout à fait ça crie ça soit dans le
fond une intervention qui soit
disponible pour autant et fermé les
médecins pour est utilisée auprès des
enfants lors de procédures une gamme de
soins finalement été fait oui et vous y
croyez bien sûr oui vous souhaite bonne
chance
merci pour tous ces enfants aussi merci
beaucoup
[Musique]